[Music]
I think we're entering the fourth wave
of scientific innovation and wealth
creation the first era was steam power
when we physicists worked out the laws
of thermodynamics we could calculate how
much energy you get from a lump of coal
to energize a locomotive or a steam
engine or a factory that was the first
big breakthrough the second wave of
innovation and wealth generation was
electricity and magnetism when we
physicists worked out the laws of
electromagnetism that gave us the light
bulb they gave us television radio gave
us the electric age the third revolution
took place when we physicists worked out
the transistor and the laser opening up
the world of high technology the fourth
wave is at the molecular level and that
is artificial intelligence
nanotechnology and biotechnology in fact
I think the synergy between
biotechnology and artificial
intelligence is going to revolutionize
everything around us first of all the
job market is going to explode in that
area because baby boomers are aging and
baby boomers have disposable income they
want answers now to their problems not
next year and so there's gonna be plenty
of money involved with people who want
to find cures for horrible diseases like
Alzheimer's Parkinson's at the present
time we have no cure for these but
tremendous amount of effort is not being
redirected toward illnesses of old age
also take a look at cancer research
we're gonna have a magic bullet against
cancer using nano medicine that is
individual molecules in the cells that
can target individual cancer cells using
nanotechnology and the next big thing is
when your toilet becomes intelligent in
the future your toilet will be your
first line of defense against cancer
because your bodily fluids blood and
your bodily fluids contain signatures of
cancer colonies of maybe a few hundred
cancer cells in your body maybe years
before a tumor
forms think about it for a moment there
are people watching this program right
now right now who have cancer growing in
their body maybe a few hundred cancer
cells in a colony but they won't know it
for perhaps ten years when you have 10
billion cancer cells growing in your
body forming a tumor we will have what
is called liquid biopsies DNA chips that
allow us to search for the signatures of
cancer colonies of 100 cells cancer
genes cancer enzymes cancer proteins
circulating in our blood and bodily
fluids so in other words one day your
toilet will tell you that you have
cancer do something you have 10 years to
do it so in other words ladies and
gentlemen what I'm trying to tell you is
in the future the word tumor will
disappear from the English language we
will have years of warning that there is
a colony of cancer cells growing in our
body and our descendants will wonder how
could we fear cancer so much cancer is
going to become like the common cold
that is we live with the common cold
it doesn't really kill anybody except
maybe if you have pneumonia
but for the most part we tolerate the
common cold because it's difficult to
cure 300 different varieties of
rhinoviruses in the future we make see
cancer the same way there are probably
thousands of different varieties of
cancer we can't cure every single one
but we'll live with it
well tolerate it and we'll eradicate it
in the same way that we live with a
common cold
[Music]